well he was really a remarkable man and
a legend in the world of retail I mean I
was there I competed against him for
many years at Tesco and he was a
formidable competitor the greatest thing
he did I think really was having taken
over a small business from his father he
rolled all the changes that happened
after the war as we moved to
self-service supermarkets and big
supermarkets and so on and so forth
modernization of the supply chain and
all the way through he kept an uncanny
feel for customers and what customers
wanted is it fair to say that he helped
transform the supermarket industry over
those decades from the 1960s onwards
yeah completely fair yes I mean there
were a couple of other people I think
you were put in that bracket you know
Jack Owen John Sainsbury in Maclaurin
and Terry Lee he of course subsequently
but Kenan was right in the forefront of
all of that that change from shopping in
small stores you know serviced over the
counter to the self-service supermarket
revolution and the supply chain changes
that came with that after the war ken
was very much in the forefront of all
that Ken's father fat William founded
the business in 1899 and and did very
well you know he built it up into a
couple of small shops and some market
stalls but when Ken finished at Bradford
Grammar School after the war he's the
youngest of six children he went to do
national service and whilst he was on
national service in Germany
his mother rang him to say that his
father was ill and did he want the
business or should she sell it in order
to to pay the bills and so he said well
when I get back from national service
I'll have a go and he he took it on and
and he built it from that small
beginnings of a few market stores in
Bradford to a business that was well
inside the footsie 50 a remarkable
achievement and a life's work really in
doing that he opened the first self
supermarket self-service supermarket in
Bradford I think it was in about 1958 he
he opened the first out-of-town
supermarket in Victoria you know it's
known as the Vic within the firm we
still have that sight at a different
store now of course but that was in 1963
that was opened by Elsie Tanner in the
PG tipps monkeys in those days when TV
personalities from Coronation Street
used to do those
things and then he moved over to
Lancashire in in the late in the 70s I
think it was when he bought Dave
Wieland's
first business remember Dave Whelan who
went on to do JD Sports JJB sports I
should say you know he started off with
the supermarkets and Ken bought those in
Lancashire and moved on the business was
floated in 1967 I think I haven't got
the stats I'm afraid but the the the
shareholder returns from that had you
bought those shares in 1967 would have
been quite spectacular and and he run
the business for over 50 years retiring
in 2008 to set up his own cattle farm
basically Houghton maitain just outside
of York so a remarkable life in every
sense you competed against him for many
years whilst you're at Tesco what what
was he like to come up against well I
think everyone in the industry had a
great affection for Morrison's you know
it was a great business that we all
looked at and admired no one emulated he
didn't really invest in computer systems
while we were doing all that he wasn't
interested in club cards or any of those
kind of what he would have called
newfangled things but he he was an
absolutely fierce competitor you know at
a time when people were saying scale was
the most important thing you know Ken
had the smallest of the businesses he
had about a hundred stores before he
bought Safeway of course went on to buy
a business twice its size and as you say
rod involved in the business right up
until the end going to stores of you and
until fairly recently very much so yes
you know many times last year visited
stores with with us and was very
generous with his time very generous
with his comments on the business and
and his insights and you know remained a
very important part of the business